okay so welcome to trash Tuesday today's
guest is
my idol my Superstar my everything
Natasha Leggero Esther I feel like you
act like that about everybody I you are
special specifically I've actually
talked about you several times on here
and I think she strives to be you every
day you are the queen of short brunettes
like you're the one
and I have this is too stupid
[Laughter]
that's sort of what Dave tells me
Dave no no but Dave will be like you're
too obsessed with Natasha like you need
to view her as your peer this is weird
and I will right now formally come
forward I have a framed photo of us in
my office from when you are on Alone
Together oh that's cute because it was
like a huge moment for me that is so
sweet see I never know when to take
people seriously like I do remember
though when the first time I saw you
like in public like walking the
reservoir I think you might have bowed
at me
and I was like what's her problem or you
were like she doesn't go fully we were
like hi hi oh [ __ ]
well also I have I know that you kind of
have this issue because I've seen Sarah
Silverman like bow at me too she dotes
on you no she does yes Esther this is in
your head okay well I'll be normal for
moving forward for the rest of the
podcast no but I have noticed with like
like the very young comedians that are
coming up a lot of people are like oh my
God queen I'm obsessed with you but then
I like notice they say that to everybody
that that is that's like a thing right
yeah that's a thing right is it yeah
it's like oh you're on fire Queen
Vibes I love you so much Stan and then
you see him like say it to everybody
yeah that's like support you know is
that is that bad
um it's a it's an approach
I mean I don't think it's bad I don't
think anything's bad you know I'm trying
to I'm trying to think like when I was
really
I'm trying to think like how I treated
people who I was obsessed with or who I
looked up to like you know Sarah
Silverman or TIG like what would I do
um probably I would just recede into the
background more I don't know I don't
remember
life is a blur
um okay so I'm gonna try to be normal
and not maybe we should let kalila talk
okay wait kalila so you still have your
podcast with Bobby I do okay what other
questions do you have for me but you
guys aren't going out anymore we're not
no okay we're not going we can't be
together or were you married I don't
know no we weren't you can't there was
one point there was one point where he
um did kind of this reverse proposal
thing where before he left for a big
trip sometime during the pandemic he was
like hey you should plan a wedding
and I'm like excuse me you should plan
away yeah with no proposal no proposal I
was like what does that mean he's like
yeah we should just you know do it and I
remember crying and like he asked me no
the opposite and
um yeah and that that was as close as we
got to um a proposal he's married to the
stage he is married to the stage and
Bobby is you know he he he was the first
person I'm sure many people have this
story but he was definitely the first
person to ever go out on a limb and help
me see that he is you too yeah yeah and
in a very that's a very that's a I mean
that's a pretty special quality because
I feel like a lot of people
um you know just in asking people to do
their podcasts you know because I have
my book coming out and people a lot of
people
you know I think women are more
competitive and having someone like
Bobby who's just always trying to help
even if it's
for weird reasons which I don't think it
is I mean it's just like how he breathes
you know he's like needs to be like
helping and doing well when he sees
something special in someone he cannot
let go of it and he really Hypes him up
so I think he's a really good hype man
in that way
um so if you've ever been someone that
Bobby has either brought on the road or
has to talk nicely about I think it
really it's not one of those I stand you
Queen he's really it's really no he got
me an agent
he's like I can't think of one person
who I he's gotten everyone agents
commercial agents has he gotten you an
agent but he took you out to
um
um meals a lot he took me out to
Applebee's once
we definitely have had shared a blooming
onion he would take you to an Applebee's
we've gone to like Thai food Denny's all
the classic classy joints and all the
classic male comedian thoughts yeah
swingers yeah well I'm sorry to hear
that you broke up I know he was very in
love with you you seemed like a great
couple but you also seemed almost like
his nurse
yes like his fantasy nurse
this show is sponsored by betterhelp as
the world's largest therapy service
better help us Match 3 million people
with professionally licensed embedded
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
and if things aren't clicking you can
easily switch to a new therapist anytime
it could not be simpler no waiting rooms
no traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
trash Tuesday that's betterhelp help
help.com
trash Tuesday
hi guys I am back on the road and I'm
coming to Seattle Portland uh
San Francisco and Phoenix get tickets at
astronice.com and I have a solo podcast
it's called my pleasure and you can
listen to it wherever podcasts are
available I am on the road I'm bringing
uh Jesse Jet Ski juicy Johnson with me
to San Jose next weekend on the 11th and
12th with Josh Potter maybe that's two
weekends from now I don't know math or
calendars it's going to be so fun please
come out to that one 17th and 18th I
will be in Plano Texas then
um we just added some more dates I'm
going to be in Las Vegas I'm going to be
in Michigan I'm going to be in a bunch
of places go to annieleterman.com shows
I cannot wait to meet you guess what
slugs we're coming back for another
Wilder and crazier and way better live
stream yeah baby we're coming back
I'm scared we should have a doctor on
site are we even allowed to talk about
this I feel like we you've heard enough
and secret time and you see it when you
believe it you see it it's going to be
amazing so fun we are going to be very
interactive with you guys on the live
stream chat and it's all going down
November 17th at 7 pm Pacific time again
you can get your tickets at moment.co
trash Tuesday get tickets at moment.co
trash Tuesday
we just took a trip to the Philippines
because we were working on this project
still we're very still Tech you took a
trip to the Philippines with your
ex-boyfriend we did but it was planned
it was pre-planned before the breakup
can I interject that fantasy nurse is
like a real thing because I have this
plan in the back of my head that if I'm
ever in a room with like scary old
Republican men that I'll just be like
I'm a nurse and then they won't hurt me
why would you say you're a nurse because
that's like a way that a woman who
they're not attracted to can still be
useful in society to them
wait is this like at the end of the
world when they're just like cutting
heads or something like any of that or
just like I wandered into the wrong golf
club and I'm nervous
so that's why I'm learning nurse words
from you through our what what makes you
think you're gonna end up in a room with
a bunch of old Republicans I think just
like the way the world is going and like
after going it's inevitable yeah and
after going on the road with Marc Maron
he like scares me about what the world
what's happening you went on the road
with Mark Maron yeah how was that like
what I just said like I feel like he's
always like right before you go on stage
he's like we're running out of water in
this country he just like scares me did
you see there they're like posting
pictures of Kim Kardashian like they
found the people who are using the most
water in LA and it's Madonna Kim
Kardashian and there was one other
person I think Sylvester Stallone and
they're using so much water for their
lawns and actually I've got a I've got a
nice lawn and now it's gray because you
can only eat water now twice twice a
week but I guess they're doing something
that's like they're putting some kind of
thing in there in in their timer to like
block it and is it a particular type of
like highly water consuming grass
because why doesn't everyone just have
Saint Augustine grass it's Hardy and it
lasts all year is that true yeah I
wonder if I have that it doesn't look as
good I love well I think it might be
more it's like long right no it's thick
it's
it's just that thick it has good um vein
long perpendicular veins on it trash
Tuesday we talk about grass the fact
that you guys can go that deep that you
just went on different kinds of oh yeah
it's a little thick Augustine yeah it is
oh you're saying it's drought tolerant I
think so I'm nurse Esther what do you
think I think that it's not as Chic as
normal grass
and when people think their lawns have
died when they've had St Augustine grass
on there they actually are not dead you
just need to re-water it it's not
um it's not a loss you just re-water it
and it'll come back alive but the end
the the point is we are running out of
water
um I I also have been trying to compost
and now my whole porch I've been
standing outside because I bought one of
those composters that you that you turn
and I've been like sitting out on my
porch and I'm like for like two weeks
I'm like what is that it's like roasting
garbage smell and then I realize it's
the sun beating down on the composter
and like the whole and I'm not putting
anything like meat or cheese in it this
is just like vegetable scraps because
then I was gonna reuse it and put it in
the grass in the in the plants and it
[ __ ] stinks so I'm actually I think
I'm gonna sell it it was 600 dollars
this is what pisses me off it's like
we're prioritizing Kim's lawn and
Kylie's private jet flying so that you
have to like smell garbage in your yard
like why am I drinking out of a paper
straw but Kylie can like fly to
Calabasas have you seen it have you seen
those flight trackers wait she flies
from Cal from LA to from Hollywood to
Calabasas she does like these like
famously short flights and I'm just like
none of us should try like this is
[ __ ] up I know but the real truth is
it's the corporations agree I mean I
think that like us like not turning on
our fireplaces or our hot tubs you know
uh
I mean
negligible I can't really speak about
this because I don't have the actual
data I feel like I know same
yeah
yeah but wait kalila back to this like
because I do agree with Natasha and it
is weird and we all kind of want to know
like
you're traveling with your ex you're
sort of living with him
he's got to still be in love with you I
mean you're like he's one of the hottest
people I've ever seen in my life kalila
he's not I mean I've met all of Bobby's
ex-girlfriends who I'm actually friends
with because you're hotter than all of
them sorry I don't remember their names
don't don't make this a clip
I've um I honestly think he is having so
much fun being single oh my God and I
look at him with so much like wait like
I feel so left behind because he's just
doing it at such a rate that I can't
like even when we were on the plane
together in first class I mean he was he
got he paid 32 dollars for the highest
speed Wi-Fi on the plane just so he
could just crush it on hinge in front of
I mean kalilah surely you're not fooled
by this I think he's like literally
doing it in front of her to try to make
her jealous to one day win you back
because he's gonna need a nurse one day
can I tell you something about Bobby
that I didn't intend to share but I know
he doesn't watch our podcast so I think
it's okay he called me last week and
because he's uh we're doing an indie
movie and he's gonna play in it and
there was a moment where like the
schedule maybe wasn't going to work but
he called me he's like I'm in I'm gonna
be able to do it and he's like do you
think I'll ever get another girl oh he
asks me that this actually no quite the
opposite he asked me if I knew a way for
him to get [ __ ] in the Philippines he
did say it that way as well
and he also said am I he
Ard he goes am I ugly and I'm just oh
he's so cute and he's very stylish and
one thing I always remember about Bobby
is he has the best taste in music he
always has great he's a cool guy no
offense like I'm super cool and he's
very funny honestly I'm sorry but do you
think you could do better I'm not sure I
think about this all the time because
he's cool
and cute and funny and helpful and he's
got a great life
right now I there's Bobby
um that is in front of the camera on
stage and then there's Bobby who's
actual shitty [ __ ] I have to wipe you
know what I mean oh you actually wipe
his ass I mean basically will you date
me
I'll do anything for that opportunity
wait no I hear you but I mean you could
also be like hey here are the the rules
this is what I'll accept this is what I
won't accept and see if he'll comply
because I think like like that I bet I
mean guys like that who've been
Bachelors for like
37 years or whatever it's like it's it's
a you know it's hard for them yeah and
also like we got together 10 years ago
in my 20s and I'm just not that person
anymore and I think maybe I was so
willing to just like give my all and you
know make him my entire identity and I
just I don't know it's hard though
because you know we've been in a
relationship for 10 years right I've
been in a relationship for 10 years I
don't feel like I'm the person that I I
was
when I met my husband you know and I
think that you're always changing and
always growing so you really do have to
find someone who is capable and open
enough to grow with you and right and
did you always feel like he was still
trying to get to know you as you were
changing
well that's a good point
I don't know break up I mean
well I do think that there is you know
it's you always have to kind of fight
against stuff sometimes you know there's
a lot of like hey you should be like
this or remember you're like this and
it's like hey you know I had a baby and
I don't want to do that anymore and now
I want to do this or maybe I don't know
what I want to do and maybe I want to
like not do anything or I don't know you
know it's so it's like it people have to
and you have to reciprocate that too
right you know you so you're also in
well you're married to a comedian you
also a comedian like is there is that
chaos because I as a comedian
could not imagine cohabitating with a
comedian but comedians there's a Moshe
comedian and then there's Bob I mean and
also Dave's a comedian yeah he's like
yeah that's true he's but he's very sane
he doesn't have that desire to be on
stage at all costs at all costs well do
you know like yeah
it's it's a thing you know and um you
know Moshe definitely has a serious
streak which I don't think Bobby has I
mean I've seen Bobby like he has like
real strong emotion for his family right
I've seen that but like I think that you
know moshe's got like you know he really
wanted a family and he really wanted
like a Jewish Family and he really you
know what I mean like uh that that part
of him was strong right so that's why I
deemed him worthy to untrace one of my
eggs or you know make an embryo do you
so you went straight with the embryo you
know I froze my eggs okay you froze your
eggs first when I was 38. oh I'm right
on time then yes are you 38 I'm gonna be
38 and oh but that was late so you
should do it no I know okay but you look
like you have a lot of eggs
she has problems we don't know what if
they've all ran out and what if those
abortions were never come we're never
gonna go full term anyways you never
know I think here's my fertility
expertise as someone who's had one
miscarriage if you can get pregnant
that's a good sign right they always say
that and then also I watch this whole
thing on Vice about how like egg
freezing is like a little bit of a scam
because if you are able it doesn't just
end at 35 it's like there's a reason at
38 you were able to get stuff because
you kind of still got it going on until
like 40 I think no no it's everyone's
individual in fact my book that's coming
out called the world deserves my
children ah title there is a chapter
called freeze your eggs and I speak all
about my journey and what you can do and
how it you know how I did it and things
have only gotten better I mean I kind of
did it at the beginning of the
technology not the beginning of it
because it started kind of in the 70s I
think I don't know but
um
but now that it's like more you know
everyone's able to do this if they want
I didn't understand at the time because
the doctor was like you you have 10 eggs
and I was like well I don't want 10
babies so that's that's fine that's he's
like do you want to do another round and
another round was another like eight to
ten thousand dollars and I was like no
no I don't even want one this is just in
case did you have the option for duo
stem huh is like you freeze your eggs
both in like the luteal phase so
basically in one cycle you're able to
extract two sets up oh I didn't even
they didn't have that then when I did it
and so basically I didn't realize then
that those eggs they sat on ice and then
when I met Moshe I was like when we
finally got married and then I tried to
get pregnant naturally it didn't work
and then finally I was like okay let's
go to these eggs because the doctors
kept talking me into not using the eggs
which I didn't understand at the time I
think they just wanted more money so
then they kept saying like why don't
those are like your savings account why
don't you try to get pregnant by like
doing all these shots so I was like
doing all these shots and then try I had
his like jizz on ice when he would be
aware way and like at the Funny Bone and
then because you can only get pregnant
for those two days a month you know
cancel those gigs I know not fair so
then I would go into the doctor's office
and every time you do one of those it's
called IUI yeah it's like 700 and they
shoot it into you and try to like you
know get you pregnant naturally so
anyway two years of that basically it's
not even naturally it's like what a
turkey yeah exactly so that didn't work
and so then the eggs I didn't understand
that I had 10 eggs but then they unfroze
them and then there was like eight and
then they made embryos and then there
was like four and then out of the
embryos they tested them for like men
you know all the mental uh problems that
could have and mosaicism make sure it's
like they're healthy and then they grade
them and so then there was two embryos
out of all of my eggs and they were both
grade C and the doctor was like there's
you know a 30 chance one of these could
be a baby right and so then we put one
up and I was like pregnant for a month
and then it died and then I had one left
and that's my beautiful baby
so I was very very very very very lucky
that one of those turned into a darling
grade a child I mean it was a c but like
it's still she was very healthy and I
don't really know why they give them
those those grades well I so I'm going
through my best friend is going through
IVF right now and
um basically now they're able when you
get the embryos they're able to even you
how they give you like oh this one's
abnormal but this one's a mosaic and
this one is normal but it's grade C
between a a is this one will be a tick
tock influencer right this one could
maybe be a mathematician but even out of
those like Mosaic embryos which they
used to say like oh you shouldn't
implant those because you know like a
certain percentage of those cells are
abnormal like some women because they
don't have a normal even C option
they're implanting the Mosaic embryo
just to kind of roll the dice
um because it is you know oftentimes you
don't get a normal embryo at all well
you have to save your money try to do
two rounds if you can or if you know how
to do two at once if that's like a new
thing they're offering but you just need
to get as many as you can and then have
your uterus this is why I understand my
doctor kept saying like your uterus is a
10 out of 10. you've got this like I
thought he wanted to [ __ ] my uterus he's
always like your uterus your uterus but
he said women's uteruses are good till
they're like you can be even be 60. like
that's how you know you see these women
when they're like pregnant at 50 miracle
baby Hilary Swank but often I don't know
about her but often those are donor eggs
so they'll get some young fertile person
and put it in but your uterus can hold
it healthily and he even told me my my
baby everything was still like I was 38
because the egg was 38 when I was from
38 even though I had my baby at 43. oh
that is music to my ears so just but you
really have to do it soon because
they'll show you a chart and like
literally like in six months you'll
probably have less eggs than you have
right now it goes fast and when you're
young you have so many that if you just
happen to [ __ ] on one of those days that
you're like uh they call them egg white
days you know what that is yeah stick
your fingers up and it's like like that
the pro there's two days like that a
month I guess when you're ovulating but
when you're when you're like 19 it's
almost like you can't not get pregnant
when you're juicing is that what you're
supposed to see oh juicy well it's it's
a sticky icky right it's the extra
clotty and it's hard because like I know
it's gross to talk about and there's men
in the room but they you know that's
actually one of the reasons why you know
just like women are embarrassed that
it's gross and that people are gonna get
you know grossed out but it's like it's
really important to know these things I
didn't really understand now what are
your thoughts on me doing it alone
just getting a sperm donor I have a
friend who did that I mean that is I
would never do that but I grew up with
that I grew up with a single mother who
like couldn't handle her three kids
because one of them had like you know
personality problems not me
um my problems are different but like
you know she was like with three kids
alone and I was like the mom so I I saw
that that's why I never wanted to have
kids but that was just not I was my my
therapist called it a situational
breeder which is like I'll breed if the
Situation's right but then there's
people maybe like you I don't know you
that well but who are like I'm having a
baby no matter what if I've gotta adopt
if I've got to do it on my own I'm gonna
have a baby and like that's great if you
have that energy and you want that heart
bad enough but like I didn't grow up
with a dad and so for me I was like I
would only do it if I met someone who
was really going to be a partner and
really going to help me out because also
like I don't know how to talk to my kid
like it's so hard and like moshe's just
good at it like I don't know know what
to say half the time wait not to be so
awkward and we can cut this but
uh I know a guy that you know who wants
to have a kid on his own do I know him
that should be that's gonna be a new
thing I think like they're gonna be like
a service or something to match people
who want to co-parent together because
honestly here's what sounds good about
co-parenting you get three days a week
off that is true yes that would be so I
know when my sister got a divorce I was
like [ __ ] this rule you have like
freeze no kids but obviously people with
their kids and they don't like that but
the legality of it is a little different
like what if he decides to just up and
move to Boston well you would have to
have a lawyer involved yeah and it would
be very I I don't know that would be
that would be hard but I don't think
you're in any hurry I think you still
have 10 more years or eight more years
or I don't know wait also the many years
you want the pro to the pitch I'm
working towards which is you having a
baby with a guy that also wants a baby
is that he's also one of Bobby's best
friends
this show is sponsored by Better Health
unfortunately life does not come with a
user manual we all know that so when
it's not working for you it's normal to
feel stuck and it's easy to stay on
stuck mode and not Solutions mode
yeah I will say this
um
better help
being online and doing everything on
there makes me think back on all of
these therapists that I was not driving
with I was not doing well with I
remember I had this therapist in college
who I could not stand do you know how
much I would have liked to have been
able to like click out of a video
just go next is there someone else I
mean the fact that like but it would be
too rude it would have been insane if I
did that it makes it really easy yeah
which is such like a
I what
what a nice thing that you don't now
have to go back on the computer and look
for another therapist under your
insurance and go all the way over there
pay for gas expensive gas and not only
that wait another month before you get
into somebody else's office
I really wish that better help had been
around in my 20s but that's okay I just
want to say like if you are someone
young and struggling and you haven't
tried therapy yet this is definitely the
best easiest option out there and I
highly recommend it and therapy changed
my life it changed the course of my life
all of our Lives actually are going to
therapy yeah and we're going through I
think this like in the last couple years
like everyone is going through just
drastic changes yeah it's insane things
are crazy and like Esther said like
therapists are kind of they're there to
help you so just identify what the real
problem is and to help you unstuck
yourself as the world's largest therapy
service better help us match three
million people with professionally
licensed embedded there therapist
available 100 online plus it's
affordable just fill out a brief
question here to match with a therapist
and if things aren't clicking you can
easily switch to a new therapist anytime
it couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms
no traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhealth.com
trash Tuesday that's betterhelp help.com
trash Tuesday I have friends who have
done it alone and I think that if you
have money to have help it could be
okay but I don't know whenever moshe's
out of town it's just like really hard
if I have a really
um reliable family like my mom I'm
always going to be help oh yeah 100 oh
yeah you should do it I just feel like
it's I didn't have that yeah my my
husband's mom is deaf and kind of has
like bad she can't really walk that well
and she gave our kids slim fast when I
had her
my dad took my child you know oh you
know where we like where we are kind of
there's that bridge yeah going against
traffic yeah he took her in the stroller
to play lotto
and he faced I facetimed him I was at
work and I'm like where are you there's
like
my kid was like six months months old
and my dad's like addicted to the
lottery he he just passed but he spent
60 to 100 a day on the lottery so he's
like very addicted to gambling so he had
to go do this so he he took my [ __ ]
child to the [ __ ] 7-Eleven I I
haven't even walked that I walked that
bridge once when I got here and I was
like oh this is unsafe
so anyway if you have like helpful
parents or you know then I think that
could make a huge difference I didn't
really have that can I interject I also
have a dad addicted to gambling who has
recently apprehended at a casino because
he legally banned himself from it and
then still went and tried to play and
then they had to arrest him because they
could lose their license if someone this
is your dad yeah and where does he play
he plays it um out in Illinois well he
so he wasn't he there's like some
casinos in Illinois he couldn't go to
those so he was driving to Wisconsin at
like one of those what does he play uh
Blackjack yeah I think so yeah all my
fans all the Italian side of my family
is addicted my grandparents lost the
deed to their my nana and papa lost the
deed to their house in Vegas and her
wedding ring wow so it's like
they they just play with whatever is
left I guess right whoa yeah that's kind
of sad wait I have a question yes let's
do me now
I really love my life like I Love Weed I
love eating writing reading
I almost had a baby I got I wanted to I
got pregnant lost it and now I feel like
I'm not really sure if I want to like I
genuinely don't know and I I do look at
you as sort of a role model that like
because oh my gosh like look at Natasha
she's lived such a full life she had her
baby later and now it seems like you're
pulling it off doing both like what's
your advice like should I or shouldn't I
well I mean no pressure I think that
it's a personal situation you know it's
like how do you do you really want to
have a baby with Dave and you guys think
you could raise it together I do think
we could
and I think that Carlos but I'll tell
you what your life becomes like
really different you know like your life
is like it's almost like it's no longer
your life you know like you don't wake
up and be like oh maybe I'll journal or
maybe I'll meditate or maybe I'll but
have a cup of coffee and play some music
or practice piano or oh what about that
book I wanted to read it's like your
whole life from the second you wake up
you're like smoothie here's the clothes
where's your sunscreen let me brush your
hair now let me brush your hair Cheerios
I don't want that here's the you know
and then like getting them in the like
every single thing is like that and I'm
sure but then you get like you know now
my kids in preschool so she's gone until
one so at least there's like that time
that I can do stuff but there's so much
to do with like cleaning and but at the
same time like I just think she's so
special and I could never imagine my
life without her and like I love her so
much and she brings me so much joy and I
feel like I like live with this like
magical creature that's just like you
know the best thing in the world but
it's like my life as I used to know it
is gone and sometimes I can kind of like
Get glimpses of it back like I'll be
like I'm going to Palms springs for two
days like I have to and I'll like leave
or something
um
so I mean that's a really personal
question like how are you adjusting to
that are you Pro like are you do you
really often long for what you had
before because I do feel like you
especially since you had her so late
like you really became
like a grown-up well that's what my
book's about is like having a child
having a child when your life is like
you know you're in your Prime because
like I've because my mom had her kids
when she was 23 like she like had
dropped out of college and then just got
pregnant and just kept getting pregnant
you know and I think a lot of our
parents kind of had a similar situation
in the 80s like you know I think that
you know women were just kind of still
getting pregnant and then they all got
divorced and the you know and I
do I so my life was very full yes that's
true but now
um
I don't know it's full in a different
way yeah that's a good way to put it
okay but it's kind of cool that you
don't just have one like
same season of your life that's a good
point like I like looking at my life as
having you know just chapters right yeah
if I'm like now I'm more inclined to
have children and to kind of have that
for myself only because I I I feel like
I can do it and I can do it alone even
like I feel so much more confident about
it now I wasn't before I was like I feel
like you could do it alone that's
another thing like I don't think I could
like I think I would just like be too
flustered or something or or be too
negative towards the kid because I just
get stressed really easily but I think
that if you feel like you could have a
handle on and you have like family help
then yes but I just think that people
like both of you should be having
children Moshe always tells me you need
to stop telling everyone to have kids
because I really do believe it like
changes your life for the better like
but then it's like it makes you less
ambitious like I don't want to go
um to Vancouver for six months and work
on something okay well same or like
Atlanta or wherever like yeah you know
and you know I I can't I just don't do
stuff then because I and I don't want to
tour and I don't want to be away from
her and you know actually sounds good
like I would love something in my life
that I love so much that it makes me not
want to do things that aren't important
anymore like that does sound like a good
thing
yeah okay I'm on board okay I think you
guys should both have kids okay but you
could also wait a little bit Esther yeah
I think I'm gonna I think I'm gonna take
my time and make this Indie yeah and
then check for your check for your egg
white days and you know get get to
plowing wait how how how does one go
through the process of
um choosing a sperm donor like what do
you think are some characteristics that
I should prioritize if I'm looking at a
page of a sperm personally I would get a
stranger yeah because I don't want to
have to share I wouldn't want to have to
share because it's not just
responsibilities you're sharing like
um you know power or control you know
like what if you want them to go to this
kind of school and he wants them to be
religious or I don't know you know what
I mean it's like you have so much more
control but I would look for um
education
that's what I would look for IQ
I have a sorry very specific answer that
I've been planning since I was in high
school which is I would personally like
to do what Madonna did for her first
baby where she made it with a tall Cuban
personal trainer and then she made like
a little mini Cuban version of herself
Lola uh gorgeous right so cool gorgeous
perfect like that's what I would do but
you would go for a physical specimen
yeah that's not a bad idea it'd be nice
to get both like I have a girlfriend who
is like 46 and she couldn't use her eggs
so she got a girl who looked very
similar to her but who went to Harvard
for math oh wow so the girl like looked
like like I think she said look kind of
like Emma Stone but also had gone to
Harvard so it's like they had just have
this right this these jeans you know so
I think you should just have sex with an
athlete and then see what happens
faster but then we would just truly
because I I was an athlete my whole life
so it's like I need too athletic of a
kid possibly because then they could
just like rely on their athleticism
their whole I know what if you like
procreate it with like kind of someone
shorter than you like maybe Asian
comedian
we were like God no I'm the world's
stupidest breakup
should you guys do it
um I think that uh probably not Esther I
think not but we did how about a
throuple the guy who you go to the
doctor with and then his best friend my
best friend
but honestly I do think there's so much
work with a child that like it's two
people isn't even enough so it's like if
you have a family and also I think in
the future maybe people like when we
during the pandemic we got together with
another family who had three kids there
was like four adults like you know
taking turns making the dinner and
taking turns doing the dishes and I feel
like living like that like would be I
mean that's probably how like people got
molested though so I don't know it's
just like it's hard because I'm you know
it would be ideal to have like a more
communal situation that is my dream for
all of my friends to live in a communist
without the [ __ ] each other who
decided that it's just a fan little
family and that's it I don't know I know
this answer what capitalism because it
is like I'm learning about this Dave is
always like you just learned this
um but like it's because that's how
everybody makes money off of us if we
like make more little houses and stuff
stay new oh right we couldn't all just
live in a big house but it would be more
fun because there's just endless work to
do right you know and and and that's
also why it's like kick your kids out at
18 so that like they have to go work and
pay bills it's so it's but I don't think
kids kids are just gonna stay at home
now right I think right I think it's
kind of cute yeah that's what I would do
obviously but my my daughter says mommy
I'm Never Gonna Leave You I'll always be
living right here and I'm like well
you're probably gonna move out you know
but she's just like
my child's very loving I don't know
maybe my my I just got lucky because I
don't mean to urge you to have a baby
like what if yours sucks
my sister always says like you make them
like perfect for you like it that's like
you can fix it have you seen Rachel
Zoe's Instagram she has this like video
out of her son proposing asking her to
marry her and then they kiss on the lips
and then the child is like I am so
fortunate to be The Offspring of this
beautiful human and I just like did she
how does she get them to act like that I
don't know that's giving Alicia
something yeah that is giving us a
Silverstone which one time she was in my
Barry's boot camp class and her son was
staring at through the glass window the
whole time and in between each session
of a workout she would run and kiss him
stop it I was like wait what was the sun
doing just staring at her working out oh
and she was working yeah which I
shouldn't judge because when I was
little and I took ballet my mom had to
stand at the window and I had to see her
the whole time but that's different
um yeah no that's giving Alicia for sure
wait I actually have a question to go
back to yes why did you decide at 38 to
freeze your eggs like what came over you
how did you come to that decision
it was like I'm just a very
kind of like what you said Kyla Emma's
always changing like I don't have any
tattoos because I know that I'm not
gonna want I I'm gonna like I wanted to
get my first boyfriend's name was Bill
and I almost got his name tattooed over
my um like right where my c-section scar
is now like I would have had the like in
like graffiti font like Bill
I'm just saying like I almost did that
so like I I know that I'm always
changing and I'm like a person look at
this this black but that looks cool I
like the blackout isn't under it as
matte oh God
so I mean I just knew that about myself
that I was always changing and always
growing and I knew I'm I didn't I I was
like who knows what I might want and if
this is the time I might as well do it
since I have the extra money you know
obviously it's a luxury to have eight
thousand dollars laying around and I
think it's probably double that now yeah
but um but yeah so so that's why you
just were like I might one day want this
yeah I'll do it and I knew that that was
I I was kind of at the cut off it's like
insurance or something right
um I think the reason I want to freeze
my eggs is so that I don't have to think
about it yeah for a while for a couple
years it takes the edge off and then
you're not like telling guys like uh
yeah I'm 40 and I really want to have
kids soon and you know it's a real game
changer for women because now it gives
women this like extra decade to like
work on their careers and like make
their own money and and find out who
they are you know like you think 20 like
at 23 I mean I'm sure some 23 year olds
know who they are but like when my mom
had kids she was just like you know and
also birth control I mean that's like a
new thing we forget like women in the
60s didn't even have the option of like
taking a pill so that they didn't get
pregnant you know they would just like
if if you [ __ ] your boyfriend and you
get pregnant what are you gonna do you
know so anyway I think that
it's it's just why not
right because the world deserves your
children kalilah thank you yours too
Esther and Dave's thank you
I'm getting pregnant tomorrow I'm turkey
basting myself with a rando do you want
uh you probably don't want Daves
you're just offering your husband's
sperm to her every day every day every
day does he want to have does he want to
have a kid uh he's he seems like he'd be
a very solid father I agree I think he's
very much uh On My Level with it where
we're we both like look at each other
and we're like we could we don't have to
like we're but I I feel like he would be
such a good dad that like we should but
yeah I think that it's this is what I
miss about not you know when I didn't
have a child I feel like I was able to
follow my Bliss a little bit more you
know my own personal what am I into you
know I'd love to like just stay home
like during the pandemic like what did
you do I would have loved to like you
know learn more piano and and take in
more classes and someone who doesn't
have a child I didn't do a goddamn thing
really did it I wasted it I laid at home
you didn't learn the G chord or anything
nothing I I have to say sorry go ahead I
journaled for exactly three days and
that was it like oh let's try something
new I journaled knows it nothing nothing
I forgot those entire two years yeah in
fact I felt like I was looking at all
the people with kids like oh my God like
score they're so lucky they have all
this time at home where they don't have
to worry about like the outside world
where they can be with their kid because
I was so anxious and scared at the
beginning of a pandemic that I made oh I
wasn't capable of making good use of my
time right I think a lot of us were
suffering from that like all I would do
is just read the news and try to keep up
because no one was telling us what to do
you know they're like wear masks don't
wear masks and it was like everything
was so confusing you almost had to like
read and read everything yourself to try
to figure out how you want to keep
yourself safe you know Lysol a lot less
all the groceries don't do that that
could you know who knows but yeah I
spent most of the pandemic doing laundry
but I do feel like people who have had
families during the pandemic well some
people got divorced but I do feel like
for certain people myself included it
made the family really close because we
were like eating I mean I was was
planning on Outsourcing 60 hours a week
to a nanny during the two years of the
pandemic and then all of a sudden I
didn't do that and I was just with my
child all the time we had like three
meals a day together like in our dining
room you know that we cooked like that
would have never happened and I was so
like magical I well I really think it
made us like a really strong family
because of that and I think I think I've
talked to a lot of people who had that
experience so
that was lucky but you know what it took
me three years to write my book because
I didn't have a nanny so it's like I
didn't really know how I was supposed to
do it you know oh are we on banana break
already
I'll take the green it's really crazy
like well it's it's also parenting
tactics you know like I was just talking
to a friend who said that she's like
yeah did your mom put hot sauce in your
mouth when you did something bad I was
like no but I did get like paddled and
then with a belt with a with a wood
thing
um I know friends who like would kneel
on the floor and on rice that was a salt
for me rock salt but I would never do
that to my child ever ever and I think
you might get your kid taken away if you
did that now you know it's funny you
when you came on tigerbelly years ago
you were the first person to tell me
that you shouldn't beat your kid
really yeah you were like
um like that's were you beaten I was
beating my whole life yeah
hard but you were like yeah that's but
not abused
abused like every emotional all of it
from your parents
but well you know what I mean I just
watched the Sinead O'Connor documentary
have you seen that no her mother
made her live in the garden for two
weeks when she was eight years old and
like her whole first album is about that
but it's like so beautiful and I'm like
if her mom wouldn't have done that would
we not have like this like you know
beautiful album of music about you know
maybe maybe I hate that that's true
about art Marilyn Monroe too watch the
new Marilyn Monroe movie she was just
like molested in foster care to clarify
that movie is based on a novel so it is
fiction which really pisses me off
because I want to know what really
happened to Marilyn I thought she was
abused she thought she was in the Foster
system for sure she was but it's like
that movie is all just based on fiction
like what the [ __ ] give me the real
didn't the actor like doesn't she still
have like an accent or something
yeah yeah
um well anyway I'm sorry that you were
treated like that but thank you for
telling me you can't beat kids no I
don't think you can even spank them
anymore right but I think that's exactly
what you told me you can't leave them in
the car like I was left in the car like
I spent most of the 80s like in a hot
like
like I just remember my mom like always
at the post office always at the grocery
store do you not do you remember that
you're did your parents do that too I
was like always it was across the board
accepted I was either in the car or like
so bored out of my mind and like a Crate
and Barrel like I remember for years I
was like I'm never going inside a crate
and bra I'm never going to an antique
store I'm never like I was just always
standing there while my mom was shopping
for something maybe they you've heard of
like French parenting yeah where they
take their kids everywhere no matter how
inconvenient yeah that's what they do
yeah like European style of parenting is
very different where they take them to
all the dinners they don't do like the
nanny thing Hey listen and I love that
and whatever I'm doing is probably
[ __ ] up because like I went to a party
and it's not just me it's everybody I
know I went to this party recently and
every parent was just standing over
their child while the child was like
playing in the play in the play box you
know and it's just like that's just what
we do now it's like so hard to not
helicopter because look I'm only having
one I can't have any more it's like
she's so important to me I don't know
what would happen if anything were to
ever happen to her so it's like and I'm
just like it's so that's what I talk
about in the book a lot is the fear it's
like you have so much fear like what
could happen you know and like every
time she she goes in a car with someone
else I'm like fantasizing about someone
flipping the car and what will happen
and you know what if something happens
to her and it's like it's this you've
given birth that's another thing I was
gonna say like if you have a baby it's
like I used to have all this schwabeeve
and you know I always wanted to like I
was never afraid of anything I would go
white water rafting without a helmet
like what ever I was just down for
whatever and now I'm just like
scared and and like giving birth to this
love is like giving birth to this fear
and it just gets worse and worse I mean
you think it's going to be better when
she's 12 or sexually active or driving
herself You Know It's Just Gonna Keep so
it's like learning how to manage your
fear you know that's why it's good to
have a partner for me because he can
sometimes be like hey you need to stop
thinking like that hey she's gonna be
fine you know hey that's just like fear
fear you know and just someone to keep
you grounded and down to earth about it
because I'm just like always Imagining
the worst I mean yesterday she was like
Mom I I choked on some popcorn and
couldn't breathe for three minutes and
I'm like where were you where were you
you know at the synagogue okay well
let's emotion what happened he's like I
was there it was pretty scary
you know I don't know what to do or like
the other night she like was stuffing
beads up her nose she was like going to
sleep with a handful of beads and then
shoving him up her nose and I had to
like get tweezers to take them out I
don't know what could have you know it's
like they're
they're they also are people they're
like these people who could hurt
themselves at any second you know so
you're giving birth this thing that you
can't live without that is like your
whole world now revolves around every
decision you make is like because of
this thing and then they can also like
hurt themselves so easily how do you cut
your parents but our parents I don't
know what they were thinking they were
just like I'll leave them in the car
whatever do they just like were they not
as into us
um yeah I can't tell my mom also had me
really young yeah I think she wanted to
kill me I think she wanted me gone this
is the mom that you're gonna let watch
the baby that you're gonna have with she
has athlete when I see her with my
nephews and nieces she is just this
tender like overtly loving and that
makes sense people change like they
mellow I rage out when I see her do that
like I I literally I'm like you can't do
that like I'm the person who then
polices that then I'm like why are you
doing that I I get so you don't want her
to be tender maybe you shouldn't be a
mom well no it's because it's like this
she does this it's almost like she with
my knees she showers her with my niece
is 20 now so much love and affection
that she still doesn't show my sister
and I she's still very like physical oh
my God my mom does the same thing though
but with like waitresses we'll be at a
restaurant my mom has only seen my kid
twice but when I've seen her we'll be at
a restaurant she's like oh what's your
name
oh Julia you're so cute I just love you
where are you from and just like so into
the waitress and I'm like hello I'm your
daughter you know so I think that's like
a defense mechanism yeah maybe my mom
doesn't give it up for anyone so I'm
good she just doesn't care about me or
anyone else you know what's really funny
you guys know Bonnie McFarlane right
yeah yeah she told me once that she's
like
um strippers have daddy issues and
female Comics have mommy issues
and I think it's really true because
every female comedian I know does seem
to have some kind of like weird mom
problem
I wonder I always feel like my like
origin story is just that my older
sister who is eight years older than me
like and way prettier skinnier taller
bigger boobs whatever like all the guys
liked her she just like would not hang
out with me or let me in her room so I
ever like barely like it was such a rare
occurrence well that's probably because
she had to take care of you yeah oh no I
don't blame her are you guys friends now
yeah we're we're so cool now but like I
just feel like I'm always so desperate
for like an older sister to like let me
in their room like that's like my whole
personality like me exactly I see okay
now we see it it's not about me it's
about you
it's my problem but you I did you were
amazing as a host on That 70s house you
remember that yes I watched that every
Tuesday I think that's so cute isn't
that embarrassing
it was a good show yeah Natasha was a
like funny sexy 70s host named Don on an
MTV show it's the you know those shows
that like your first show that makes you
not have to like be a waitress anymore
yes yes
well I'm sorry you went through that
color that's okay that's that's really
that's really harrowing but maybe that's
why you're successful
successful because I look at my friends
um that I grew up with and everyone is
just thriving emotionally it seems and
they seem I I was definitely stunted
um most of my late teens and 20s I
didn't I was not a bright teenager I was
very Reckless and I yeah so um and I was
stunted I I don't believe that
um the bad stuff is what made me who I
am I think I would have been a far more
um
actualized Human by now if I didn't like
suffer what I suffered it's impossible
to know that you're doing the right
thing when you're raising a kid right
it's so hard and everyone you know all
these like Mommy blogs I follow all
these people on Instagram it's like
how do they know how do they know that
that's the right thing to do like
they're always like don't say don't say
good job to your kid you have to say you
have to say you worked really hard on
that or don't say be careful because
then that then they'll always be scared
like there's just all these things that
you naturally do and they're like don't
help them you know put on their shoes if
they can do it themselves it's like oh
well I gotta go you know and it's like
and what are they basing this on I don't
really know I mean they're probably
right but still it's like it's not like
we have a whole crop of kids who've
grown up with all of these doctors
telling us what to do and seeing what
happened I mean we saw what happened
when we stopped hitting the kids we got
Millennials
like basically like wait what's my well
I'm just saying like it's a little
different like like my generation we
were all spanked and hit right and like
left in cars and then like don't you
think like as a rule aren't Millennials
just like a little more precious or
something I mean not you personally but
like I don't know know like yeah yeah no
totally it's just a different vibe I'm
just saying like we don't really know
what works like right and
who knows but what if any then what is
Gen z a result of like what were the
parents of gen Z like is that like
a Gen X or something yeah I think that
are slightly hardier in some ways yeah
but but it just depends on what age you
had your kid yeah oh that's true you
know what I mean because because my kid
is four but like you know I'm older so
right
how did how is that like it doing school
stuff and being around the other moms do
you feel like you're the same age older
all moms in a layer old okay you would
be like people would think you were an
eighth grader you went to pick up your
kid did you okay so like
I always feel like I came up in comedy
like when it was still really misogynist
and you were before me so it was like
probably even worse I have this
I don't know if it's like a chip on my
shoulder or something I just feel like
all these older men when I was younger
like ingrained this idea in me that I
have an expiration date because I'm a
girl and that like once I'm like 30 I
would be ugly and have no use in society
and I feel like
this concept has then like made me swing
the other way so hard where I'm just
like [ __ ] you guys like because that of
that like I'm going to prove that
actually like in well into your 30s and
Beyond like I'm going to be able to be
accomplished so much and still be useful
whatever like did you have that any
voice in your head and do you relate to
that okay well I remember I was like
with this comic and he was describing
someone to me and I was like who is that
I won't say who it was and he was like
you know that girl she's blonde she's
just starting to lose her looks like
that's how he was trying to describe to
me who she was like I would know that
from you know his description and I
think that like and again the Sinead
O'Connor documentary I was watching that
this is a little different but like
every single guy uh interviewer was like
you shaved your head you shaved your
head what happened to your long hair you
know and like everyone wants you to have
long hair and have big boobs and you
know be young and I think that the only
answer to any of this the only only
answer is like more women make making
content more women writing more women
being in charge in the positions of
power to Green Light things about women
and like we just have to have more women
helping each other producing for each
other interviewing each other talking
about each other writing parts for each
other acting each other's things and
it's just like it just sort of and and
also inspiring young women you know like
I went to an art school so I was very
lucky like I got into an arts program
but like I know out of the public
schools out here it's like the Arts are
like they're pretty much taking them
away because they can't afford it and
it's like the Arts are so important and
I think that just grooming people you
know like for example I know so many
guys who went to NYU film school I know
no women who went to NYU Film School in
the 90s like me you know I bet I bet the
classes were like two women out of like
and like 50 men and like men just have
always believed they could be directors
and so and producers and so they do it
and they go out there and they just like
you know flop their dicks around and I
think like the more women
and I talk about this a little bit in
the book because like you know I
remember hearing Amy polar talk about
like sticking up for herself in this
like some guy was kind of talking down
to her at an awards show and she just
stopped and was like don't talk to me
like that and then she got what she
wanted and you know and I remember I was
on my way to work and I had to stand up
to this editor and I had heard her just
talk about doing that and then I stood
up to this editor and I was like that
morning I just after I was listening to
the audiobook I was like you know what I
don't want you talking to me like that
you can get another job and I had never
talked to a man like that and he was
like oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry it
was my show you know but I was still
being treated like [ __ ] and it was
because of the modeling that I had heard
that she did it and so I think that like
the more we can set an example and just
we just need more women more women doing
it and that's really the only answer to
that because then women are like wait
I want to see women in their 40s and 50s
like that's some of the like have you
rewatched Sunset Boulevard lately it's
like amazing and she's like this like
she had us a tattooed and Tattoos what
oh really my favorite movie it is yeah
but I mean look at her she Gloria
Swanson's like in her 40s but she looks
like she's in her 60s you know but her
what's going on with her is so
fascinating and I think women are
fascinating and like I always tell Moshe
like he'll want to go see these movies
and I'm like if there are five men on a
billboard I am not watching that movie
it's so boring to me like I'm so much
more interested in women women are I
like what women on stage are more
interesting they're beautiful they're
good to look at like they they have such
an interesting point of view they give
birth like they just have they deal with
men I mean there's just like so much
more to it to me personally I mean I
don't mean to be sexist like that but
for me personally I'm just way more
interested in a woman's journey and I
just think that modeling that and that's
how we'll get more of it
so start production companies I guess
the three of us right now I mean don't
you what do you think what do you
think's the answer I don't know I mean
that's just
I agree like I I feel the same way and I
feel like I all I can do is like I only
have control over myself so I just like
try to stay really motivated and like
hear those voices like I literally have
a relative who I've heard on the phone
with my parents be like oh you know
that's nice Esther's having some success
like you know she'll hit her 30s it'll
fizzle out but yeah and I like
that is just always going to be there
and I'm just always going to feel like I
have to prove that wrong I think and
so it's like that's like it's like
saying women aren't funny I mean it's
like literally not true just like go
look at Jane Fonda's Instagram or you
know what I mean like you can just find
those people who Empower you and like
look at what they're doing and I mean
why would it end right I mean when a
man's 38 he's what like finally ready
for pet ownership like but a woman's
like completely expired again
both of you just so you know see how
young and hot you are if you go get
pregnant right now just so you know the
doctor is if it's a man we'll call it a
geriatric pregnancy because it's over
34. so it's like you know this is the
same time a man's ready to like you know
what get his own apartment it's like
it's so annoying stock toilet paper yeah
finally own a plan so I think it's just
like I think we just have to be really
strong and like not let those things
it's like same thing with fear and my
baby like I just have to like just kind
of be bigger than it you know and it's
obviously hard and I think it's like
requires you to
dig a little deeper in yourself a little
bit and you know to to try to figure out
how to not be afraid of every single
thing you know yeah Lexapro has helped
me with that
five milligram gang every day yeah you
know ketamine really helped me out it
did I cannot begin to describe the
immediate effects that doesn't have
antidepressants so I I'm
I am I don't do any drugs I don't smoke
weed I maybe drink like twice a year
um and
um boring really really boring Natasha
twice a year because then you're not
even sober you're like you like on your
birthday right I'll have a Cosmopolitan
right right super boring I'm super
straight edge in that way but when I was
going through just like the
The Bluest of Blues and this is like
right after my breakup
um I really just want I I I thought I
was going to have a nervous breakdown I
was like oh [ __ ] like I am not going to
come out of this alive I don't think and
I did ketamine with a a therapist and a
doctor and the effects were immediate
wait from doing it once once and I've
been on antidepressant so you don't you
don't micro those not I don't microdose
I it's almost as if I just don't have
that like the quickening of my heart
when I'm like anxious like I'm super
anxious I'm always sweating I just don't
have that currently like I'm able to
just kind of exist not necessarily like
Overjoyed but I'm able to just get
through my days without fearing
um every tiny thing that happens from
doing ketamine that one time one time I
can't like did you have like an epiphany
that you remember that like no I had the
worst ketamine journey I think of all
ketamine Journeys I thought I was
physically dying like it was so now
you're like I'm glad I'm alive I think
so it was so scary like I overdosed uh I
might have it was so scary and so grim
and so dark I cried for 90 minutes I
couldn't breathe it was I was a
therapist was there yeah and a doctor as
well checking your heart rate and all of
that stuff and it's been like for like
three months now and I am just able and
I was was not able previous to that I
mean I was like oh I think I'm gonna
probably kill myself and now I'm like
holy [ __ ] it works what did you tell
them you said I have like unbelievable
yeah I am so depressed I am at my wits
and I think I am
starting to I never want to say that I'm
like oh I have suicidal ideation or
anything like that because it'll like
lock you lock you up for that but I was
like I don't know how to get through my
days anymore like I'm I've never tried
weaving
I used to smoke a lot and it worsened my
anxiety a little bit
um but I cannot believe how well it's
working I just am able can you is there
any way to articulate like what it
changed for you because I know like for
me when I have gotten like super high
off weed or like you know dabbled in
psychedelics like I
it like ex like you see so many things
more clearly and like you feel like did
you have any can you I I didn't I wasn't
even nothing I had no great visual like
Awakening or anything like that I just
got sad like all the sadness like came
out at once I think it felt like a
purging for me maybe and it was so
difficult and I was so uncomfortable and
I couldn't move my body and it they talk
about this like Afterglow afterwards and
you kind of feel a little bit like high
still
um but it's Frank for example
um just
I I passed five hours of a flight alone
I can't take like I'm so afraid to
travel alone
but now I'm like oh I can do anything
I'm not afraid of anything I can drive
anywhere oh that's why Bobby was invited
on your
right right had I taken Kennedy before
that he would have not been invited but
now you can handle it I can
I can handle it that's amazing what were
you afraid of taking a flight by
yourself everything because I get panic
attacks I'm like what if I get a panic
attack on a 20 a 15-hour flight
you know um what if and then no one can
help me and I think I'm because I I you
know right my dad would never go on a
flight more than two hours so if he came
to LA from Chicago he would take a he
would stop at a layover to use the
toilet he's like I'm not using a toilet
on an airplane
his whole life was like a lot about
where he could tell you the toilet
that's relatable well that's amazing
that that made you better yeah I mean
who knows for how much longer I feel
like the effects are waning a little bit
because I'm kind of starting to get like
a little bit sad but I'm like oh I could
just re-up
yeah I would
you know it's never worked for me really
I think I need like a very large dose
huh but have you taken them a lot so
I've tried it probably like five or six
times no it's never like work what
that's weird I swear to God I've tried
psychedelics and it has not worked
that's so funny because I knew a girl
who did not feel anything from Ayahuasca
no I swear to God and everyone around
her was just so [ __ ] up and she was
like nope I nothing no Revelations
nothing nothing that's weird so that
might be the equivalent equivalent of
you and mushrooms oh gosh did cannabis
help you write your book
I mean I definitely will use weed
sometimes to like try to expand my mind
like especially when I'm
thinking about ideas like parenting at
the end of the world or like fear and
love and how they're connected and like
you know just kind of like thinking
about these Concepts that you feel but
you don't quite know how to express so
you know I I find for me like writing
sometimes if I'm if I'm ever stuck that
can that can help yeah that's what I've
noticed too like I feel so much more
expressive and creative and like in
touch with myself from like trying
cannabis yeah trying to be formal it's a
match
well that's another thing it's like it
has to agree with your personality you
know because it's like if you're already
super chill like her weed might make her
turn her into an idiot
because she's just like so calm and so
chill where it's like I used to be like
way more like
thirsty yeah oh I'm so thirsty yes
that's a really good word for me but
weed can like chill that out a little
bit I think so can meditation so can a
lot of things I think
but I remember like my first comedy
teachers or like people who I would take
like when I moved to LA I took like I I
went to an audition and there was
comedians there and I was like whoa
these people are way cooler than the
actors like I want to be a comedian like
who are these people it's they all seem
so funny so then I took like improv like
it's a one-person show class stand-up
comedy clot like Groundlings uh Second
City any like I took every single class
like unless if it wasn't in Long Beach I
would take it like I took sketch writing
like a sitcom writing I mean I was just
always in a class but I remember I saw
one of the teachers like three years
later and he was like whoa you've
changed so much you know because I think
I was just like I was just like anything
anything like because I just didn't know
and
you know when you don't have parents or
anyone guiding you or mentors you kind
of are just like Flying Blind you have
to like lap it all up to figure out you
don't know what you're doing you know
so do you remember who those comedians
were at the audition who you thought
were cool no but I do remember like you
know how like actors you come back from
an audition and they're like in the
waiting room like someone will come out
and they're like I remember this girl
was like I got adjustments
like the person that gave her like like
the casting director gave her
adjustments and so she was bragging and
trying to psych out the other actors and
like the comedians were just like I mean
they're all [ __ ] up too but at least
they're funny right you know and I was
just like and I knew that I was funny
because people would laugh but I didn't
really know how to harness that or what
to do so that's why I was like just
really trying to figure it out for like
probably took me like three years and
like nine thousand dollars in classes to
like try to I remember I took a
growling's class and after the first the
first
um class was done you had an interview
and the teacher was like good job we're
gonna invite you to repeat
and that's how they would say like
you're invited to repeat the class again
so like it was like a lot of that stuff
like trying to find my FIT you know and
then I think like with stand up
I just kind of got lucky and like it
just worked the first time I tried it
and I was like this is amazing so then
it was then I just kept doing that
I think I was such a ball of anxiety
when I started because I I feel like
when I was in an audition room I would
literally make the worst impression
possible on everyone I would be like I'd
walk in and if I saw like a group of
women sitting there I'd be like
how long has everyone been waiting what
how behind are they like I was just like
like I was walking to a doctor's office
I was such a I was like what I can't do
this like sometimes I would leave like I
was just I thought I was too busy even
though I had nothing else to do I just
couldn't like sit the pain handle the
pain of like having to wait it like made
me so offended or something I think
being a comedian you're always gonna say
stupid [ __ ] I just always say stuff I
regret I can't stop I just it just
happens all the time I'm just always
feeling like why did I say that yeah but
that is actually such a good thing
because that's like how you achieve like
the Flow State or that's like how you
it's like for every 100 stupid things I
say
three of them will be like something
important to someone that's good right
it could be great stats
that's three percent success rate yeah
well Natasha thank you so much for being
here today with us I feel like we've
learned a lot well thank you guys
um when so much when does the book come
out
um my book The World deserves my
children comes out November 15th but it
is available for pre-sale now and uh
cover is so good thank you this is my
kitchen that's my child try to not show
her face so she doesn't hate me that's
one thing I wanted to ask about actually
okay parents who make um Pages for their
children like Instagram pages I mean I'm
just too paranoid
you know would you think that at some
point that will have some implications
for that I mean I I'm assuming I don't
know I mean I've seen first of all I
remember being with a friend and her 10
year old was with us and some people at
the party were like oh I recognize you
from Instagram to the 10 year old so
like that's something that I was like oh
clocked that I don't want that to happen
and then I also heard of a girl like
suing her parents for like putting
images of her out and then my daughter's
always saying these funny things so I
tell people and she'll hear me and she's
like Mom don't you say everything that I
say don't tell people things I say and
then I'm thinking like wait my whole Act
is about her so now here's my new plan
what do you guys think of this just not
gonna record a special
so she'll never know no do it no then
I'll just like travel if you want to see
me come to one of my dates I'm doing a
book tour and I'll be talking about
everything but I'm thinking like maybe I
won't put it in anything concrete so she
can never watch it when she's 12. she
can't do you or sue me or whatever I'm
gonna do a bootleg filming of it
the world deserves my comedy you know
people can just come see me
um well I really am excited for you guys
to switch out those screensavers into
babies
you can do it wait where do we um get
information about seeing you on tour uh
you can go to my Instagram and I'll have
all my tour dates listed and uh pre-sale
you can get the book now
or you can you know get the pre-sale and
then you get it but they all count
towards uh
you know making it a New York Times
bestseller I think we're gonna do that
well thank you girls thank you Natasha
dream come true
see you guys next week
[Music]
thank you
[Music]